una captura en vivo así narraba desde un
aeropuerto el senador Eric Morón la
detención de Luis Fernando Camacho
gobernador de la región de Santa Cruz
fue aprendido por el caso golpe de
estado 1 y lo anunció la fiscalía en
Twitter La decisión fiscal no se trata
de un secuestro o persecución política
por el contrario fue emitida en el mes
de octubre de la presente gestión y
cuenta con control jurisdiccional del
juez decimo de instrucción en lo penal
del tribunal departamental de justicia
de la paz Los partidarios de Luis
Fernando Camacho bloquearon dos
aeropuertos y calificaron la detención
de secuestro ya que aseguran que no
había citación para el dirigente y que
se le capturó con violencia la
información confirmada es que los
secuestraron en las proximidades de su
domicilio donde fue
interceptado por vehículos donde
hicieron uso de armas de fuego para
encañonar a las personas que lo
acompañaban y lo trasladaron con destino
a este aeropuerto de Virgilio de ahí en
más no podemos establecer con precisión
su paradero Santa Cruz es la mayor y más
rica región de Bolivia está gobernada
por el tercer partido más representado
en la asamblea nacional sobre Luis
Fernando Camacho pesa la acusación de
terrorismo por los hechos sucedidos en
2019 después de las elecciones en las
que habría ganado el expresidente Evo
Morales surgieron protestas con
Epicentro en la misma Santa Cruz que
terminaron con la renuncia de morales y
su salida del país además de 37 muertos
en las calles por ese mismo proceso
también está acusada la expresidenta
interina gianáñez quien ya fue condenada
a 10 años de prisión por el caso golpe
de estado dos